vor 35 Jahren sollte ein
wirtschaftliches Experiment in den USA
und im Vereinigten Königreich ein
besseres Leben für alle ermöglichen
heute ist die Ungleichheit in beiden
Ländern auf dem höchsten Stand seit
[Musik]
1928 ich bin Einzelkind ich hatte eine
großartige Kindheit ich zi tolle Eltern
die mir alles gegeben haben was ich
brauchte ich dachte ich könnte fliegen
als ich jung war ich meine wir waren arm
aber da war so viel Liebe dass wir das
gar nicht richtig gemerkt
haben wir sind in einer Umgebung
aufgewachsen in der wir nie wirklich
wussten was passieren würde und das
schafft eine Menge
Unsicherheit im Vergleich zu früheren
Generation vielleicht ein bisschen Klamm
wir können uns vielleicht nicht das
beste paar Schur leisten aber wir leben
nicht in
Armut wir verdienen sehr viel Geld
wirklich sehr viel Geld es ist ja nicht
so dass wir im Lotto gewonnen haben und
in ein großes schickes Viertel gezogen
sind meine integrität ist das was ich
habe wissen Sie vor langer Zeit hat die
Integrität der Leute noch was
bedeutet
[Musik]
ich bin glücklich in den apalachen
aufgewachsen wir hatten schöne
Weihnachtsfeste wir hatten liebe ich war
normal aber
jetzt was zum Teufel bin ich
jetzt
können sie mich
hören keine Herausforderung ist
dringlicher wir können uns entweder mit
einem Land abfinden indem es einer
schrumpfenden Zahl von Menschen wirklich
gut geht während eine wachsende Zahl
kaum über die Runden kommt oder wir
können eine Wirtschaft wiederherstellen
in der jeder eine FA Chance bekommt
jeder seinen fairen Beitrag leistet und
jeder nach den gleichen Regeln
spielt
die Vereinigten Staaten sind mit einer
wirtschaftlichen Notlage von großem
Ausmaß konfrontiert es ist an der Zeit
diesen Industriegiganten wieder zu
erwecken die Regierung wieder auf ihre
Mittel zu beschränken und unsere
Steuerlast zu verringern bei diesen
Grundsätzen wird es keine Kompromisse
geben gehen Sie zurück an die Arbeit
oder
nicht der Betriebsrat hat den Krieg
erklärt
wieder ein Arbeitskampf diesmal sind es
die Lastwagenfahrer was zu Panikkäufen
in den Geschäften und auf den Märkten
führt man hatte das Gefühl dass was auch
immer die Regierung zu tun versuchte die
Dinge nicht gerade besser machte das
könnte die Dinge sogar noch schlimmer
machen ich war der Meinung dass der
freie Markt die Ressourcen hervorbringen
würde mit denen es allen besser gehen
könnte das Argument war wenn du das oder
das machst sindt die Arbeitslosigkeit
dann gibt es mehr Investitionen und mehr
Einkommen das nach unten
durchsert
ohne große Belohnungen werden Leute wie
ich nicht 15 bis 20 Stunden pro Tag
arbeiten reich werden zu
[Musik]
können das ist
schlecht während meiner doktorantenzeit
wurde mir gesagt dass Psychen dieit
jtizieren durchschnittlich 100000 im
Jahr verdienen und ich dachte das klingt
mies das war eine Art Ansporn für mich
zu den oberen 1% zu
gehören ich gehöre nicht zu den obersten
1% der Welt eher in der Welt der
Psychologie ich habe mir das ausgesucht
ich fahre lieber ich könnte einen Zug
nehmen direkt in die Stadt aber dann
würde ich vielleicht krank werden wenn
ich mit all diesen fremden Menschen in
einem geschlossenen Raum bin in der
Öffentlichkeit an diesem Punkt meiner
Karriere kann ich es mir nicht leisten
krank zu werden jeder Tag zählt wenn ich
das Haus abbezahlen
will jetzt noch 10 Minuten um mit dem
Kaffee in der Hand zur Arbeit zu
gehen ich hole mir meinen Kaffee mit
Espresso short und gehe mit meinem
Rollkoffer direkt ins
Büro normalerweise bin ich um
5R ich mache das Licht an setz mich hin
und dann geht's los bang bang bang eine
Sitzung nach der
anderen so geht das nonstop ich kann
diese kleine Kiste von einem Büro nicht
verlassen ich habe niemanden mit dem ich
reden kann ich muss das Gebäude nie
verlassen außer zum Mittagessen dann
sitze ich da alleine an einem Tresen in
einem Restaurant auf der anderen
Straßenseite und das ist für mich der
Himmel wenn ich die New York Post
lese
[Musik]
und wieder
unterwegs
der Montag beginnt sonntags und endet
erst am daraufolgenden Freitag sobald
der Montag kommt geht's los jeden Tag
jeden
Tag es ist ein ständiger Kampf alles
macht ein bisschen
Stress ich sag's dir noch
einmal lass das da
drin mach es
zu wenn ich in richtigen stressmodus
gerate rauche ich zu viel was weiß
ich
aber du kannst bei der Arbeit ja nicht
trinken wenn das möglich wäre hätte ich
einen Flachmann
dabei wir haben Kartoffelecken oder
grüne Bohnen oder Mais oder maaroni und
Käse könnten sie das noch mal
sagen Mais makaroni und Käse
Kartoffelspalten oder grüne
Bohnen
kofelb können sie sich nicht einfach
entscheiden was sie nehmen ich versuche
ihnen zu helfen ich sag's ja nur helf
mir alles ist gut es ist nur so oh man
weißt du mach mal
Piep mehr als jeder vierte Mann ist
arbeitslos letzte Woche wurden weitere
600 Entlassungen
angekündigt
die Einkommensunterschiede haben sich
seit Mitte der 80er Jahre rapide
vergrößert je schwächer die
Gewerkschaften sind desto mehr
Ungleichheit gibt es das ist ein sehr
auffälliger
Zusammenhang die Arbeitslosen von heute
sind die Opfer der Fehler von gestern
aber das ist Vergangenheit die Regierung
drückt die Inflation senkt die Zinsen
reformiert das gewerkschaftsrecht baut
Vorschriften und Einschränkungen
[Musik]
ab
das Machtgleichgewicht zwischen
Arbeitgebern und Arbeitnehmern hat sich
zu Gunsten der Arbeitgeber verschoben so
ist das gewesen und ich glaube das war
ein bewusstes Ergebnis der
[Musik]
Politik
er ist noch im Bett wenn ich morgens zur
Arbeit gehe und er ist wahrscheinlich
schon im Bett wenn ich abends von der
Arbeit komme und wenn nicht wenn er noch
wach ist dann gehe ich wahrscheinlich e
bald
[Musik]
schlafen
die Kinder sind meist noch im Bett wenn
ich zur Arbeit
gehe und wenn ich dann nach Hause komme
gehen sie wieder
schlafen und ich weiß dass das Leben das
sie haben langweilig ist weil sie nicht
viel machen
[Musik]
können der huslichen PLE sicher so wie
es läuft weiß man einfach nicht was von
Woche zu Woche von Tag zu Tag passiert
ich stell ihnen das hier mal hin
vorsicht das ist heiß lassen Sie es
erstmal ein bisschen
abkühlen wenn jemand stirbt oder ins
Krankenhaus kommt ist das furchtbar aber
man denkt auch an sich selbst weil man
viele Stunden verliert wenn man nicht
etwas findet um diese Lücke zu füllen
kann ich sonst noch etwas für sie tun
nein alles gut noch vielen Dank sehen
wir uns morgen ja morgen früh komme ich
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
später Menschen werden als kaufeinheiten
betrachtet die an den niedrigsten Beater
verkauft werden eine halbe Stunde um
jemanden aufzurichten ihn zu waschen
anzuziehen ihm die Medikamente zu geben
und ein sinnvolles Gespräch zu führen
das geht
nicht ich werde hier 20 25 Minuten
brauchen
die Leute gucken auf deine Schulden ist
das alles was sie tun nein das ist nicht
alles was ich tue ich bin eine
[Applaus]
Betreuerin stay away from
[Musik]
me why don't you let me
be don't know
why you keep on Holding
me we
wir sind dorthin gezogen wo mein Mann
herkommt und wir wollten unser eigenes
Geschäft aufbauen und so und das war als
wir anfingen kauften wir eine Videothek
und als Walmart ins Videogeschäft
eingestiegen ist hat das den kleinen
Läden den Gar
ausgemacht wir hatten nicht das Angebot
das Walmart
hatte dann haben wir nach 5 Jahren dicht
gemacht
eines Tages war ich im Walmart und sie
hatten ein Schild auf dem stand dass sie
Leute einstellen und ich dachte mir na
ja kannst dich ja
bewerben als sie dann anriefen war ich
wirklich überrascht und ich war sogar
noch mehr überrascht wie gut es war in
diesem Unternehmen zu arbeiten die
Manager kamen rein und sagten ich habe
gesehen was du getan hast hey ich danke
dir bis die Veränderungen
kamen das Unternehmen wollte die
Betriebskosten senken weniger Leute die
die Arbeit machen aber trotzdem die
gleiche Menge an Arbeit du musst auch
gleich los oh
ja es ist 2 Uhr ich glaube ich gehe
heute um 4 Uhr nein 3:30r heute ist der
vite siehst du jeden Tag geht das so um
wie viel Uhr muss ich zur Arbeit das ist
einfach
nervenaufreibend und ich bin nicht die
einzige ich habe mit im ganzen Land
gesprochen und bei denen ist es das
gleiche sie fragen sich wann muss ich
morgen zur Arbeit sie glauben gar nicht
wie viel Stress das
[Musik]
macht wir leben in einer Zeit der
absolut erstaunlichen Veränderung sie
alle wissen dass die informations und
technologieexplosion ihnen und den
jungen Menschen der Zukunft mehr
Möglichkeiten und Herausforderungen
bieten wird als Generation von
Amerikanern je erlebt
[Musik]
hat es ist ein Börsenboom wie es ihn
seit den berauschenden 80 nicht mehr
gegeben
hat der Dow Jones ist in nur 12 Monaten
um fast ein Viertel gestiegen mit
Rekordgewinnen und Millionen Boni auf
dem
gehaltschecks was ich wirklich geändert
hat ist dass wenn Sie früher
Geschäftsführer waren dann war das ein
Unternehmen auf dem lokalen Markt heute
sind die meisten Märkte die wichtig sind
global
ausgerichtet wenn sie Apple Chef sind
und das Unternehmen um 3% effizienter
machen haben sie den Gewinn des
Unternehmens um 1,2 Milliarden Dollar
gesteigert ihr wirtschaftlicher Wert
erhöht sich
explosionsartig wir sind wirklich
erfreut zu berichten dass wir in diesem
Quartal 106 Millionen Dollar verdient
haben
B ges Bill Gates von Microsoft ist jetzt
29 Milliarden Dollar wert 10 Milliarden
mehr more von Intel Computing 6,7
Milliarden plus 3 Milliarden und Bill
hulet von Hul Packard ein persönliches
Vermögen von 4 Milliarden plus 1
Milliarde alles in nur 6
Monaten wenn sie an der Spitze dieses
Prozesses landen dann haben sie eine
Rechtfertigung für das was mit dem Markt
passiert der ein effizienter Weg
istessourcen
verteilen er hat mir eine Menge
Ressourcen zugeteilt also muss ich ein
effizientes Ergebnis
abliefern es muss zeigen dass ich
fleißig und klug bin und in
Anführungszeichen verdiene was ich
bekomme nur sehr wenige Menschen haben
die geistigen Ressourcen die
Energie ich meine sehen Sie mich an ich
bau eine afrikanische Kunstsammlung auf
ich Unternehmen mein jüngstes Kind ist
drei ich bin 70 Jahre alt ich habe vier
Kinder 13 und
jünger was sagt das also über mich aus
ich meine ich bin da draußen und
erschaffe
Dinge es gibt viele Dinge die die
Ungleichheit aufrech erhalten
Wirtschaftssysteme
Regierungspolitik ich würde sagen dass
auch die Psychologie eine Rolle spielt
die Art und Weise wie Menschen denken
die Dinge die sie schätzen die
Ungleichheit nimmt zu aber die Menschen
sind sich nicht bewusst was Sie tun um
dazu
[Musik]
beizutragen die meisten der bewachten
Wohnsiedlungen liegen entweder auf einem
Golfplatz oder in der Nähe eines
Golfplatzes einige der Annehmlichkeiten
sind wirklich
[Musik]
toll aber für manche Leute geht mehr
darum hinter einem Tor zu leben ich lebe
hinter einem Tor und du lebst nicht
hinter einem Tor und sieh mal wie viel
besser es ist dass ich hinter dem Tor
lebe wir haben dieses Haus nicht gekauft
um unsere Freunde auszuschließen die
kein Haus hinter dem Tor haben aber wir
hatten viele Freunde die wirklich
dachten das sei so wir hatten Freunde
die sagten nein wir werden euch nicht
besuchen kommen so in etwa ihr seid da
drüben hingezogen wir leben auf dieser
Seite es ist wirklich traurig wirklich
[Musik]
traurig im allgemeinen bleiben alle
ziemlich unter
[Musik]
sich willst du die Bananen für dein
Sandwich wir wissen nichts über unsere
Nachbarn nichts ich habe noch einen
Hamburger gefunden
eine Sache die ein paar unserer Nachbarn
wirklich auf die Palme gebracht hat ist
dass wir keinen Gärtner angestellt haben
einmal kam dieser Nachbar heraus und
starrte mich an ich war sichtlich
schwanger beim laubhaken ST einfach nur
und schreit von der anderen Straßenseite
rüber wissen sie nur arme Leute Haken
ihr eigenes
Laub wie aufgeregt bist dum das Jaguar
sei nett wie aufgeregt bist du das Haus
zu sehen ich bin sehr
aufgeregt ich glaube dass da viele junge
Leute in der Siedlung sind die so sind
wie wir ich werde eine ganz neue Gruppe
junger Väter kennenlernen die mit mir
Fußball spielen und Softball und Tennis
und ich habe das Gefühl dass das die
beste Gemeinschaft ist die wir uns
hätten wünschen können sie hat einen
großartigen Schulbezirk ich glaube wir
haben wirklich großes Glück
gehabt hat neulich mit jemandem
gesprochen und er meinte es ist ein Ort
an Plätze gibt einen Pool ein bewachtes
Tor eine Menge junger Leute und er
meinte wow das müssen die Reichen und
die großen sein ja das ist es es ist
also wie ein na ja wie ein
ungeschliffener Diamant das ist der
beste Ort in
Westchester das ist großartig ja jeder
orientiert sich bei der Wahl seines
Wohnorts an den Schulen wir werden
unsere Mädchen auf eine Schule in arsley
schicken einem der besten Schulbezirke
des Landes und es wird eine super
Lebensqualität und ein großartiges
Umfeld sein in dem wir tolle Familien
ich glaube es wird lustig weil ich dort
viele Leute treffen
werde ich habe in diesen geschlossenen
Siedlungen Leute getroffen die einfach
nur sagen weißt du rich ich will nur
dass meine Kinder auf sichere
Schulen ich MTE
meineben
prate par privateadwege private Seen sie
sind sich über die Privilegien die sie
haben gar nicht so
bewusst was gucken wir uns zuerst an
okay also wir sind jetzt in wir sind in
boulderid das ist eine große Gemeinde
mit hunderten von Häusern sie hat einen
pfner der 24 Stunden am Tag Wache
schiebt sodass niemand hierherkommen
kann ohne dass man weiß wer es
ist das heißt es hier keine Kriminalität
gibt das ist gibt mir ein sicheres
Gefühl wenn ich außerhalb der Stadt
arbeite weil ich weiß dass die Mädchen
sicher sind ja genau schöne Autos
hier ich glaube das ist der perfekte Ort
für
Sie sobald man eine bestimmte
Steuerklasse erreicht hat wird erwartet
dass man einfach so weitermacht wie es
der Steuerklasse
entspricht Autos sind eine große
Sache die meisten Leute fahren einen
Mercedes oder einen BMW oder wenn Sie
ein amerikanisches Auto fahren ist es
die neueste Version von was auch
immer es ist nicht so dass wir uns
entschieden haben einen Hyundai von 1988
zu fahren ich bin sehr glücklich darüber
dass mein Auto schon 200.000 Meilen
geschafft hat das heißt dass ich mich um
etwas gekümmert habe für dass ich eine
Menge Geld hingelegt habe aber so wird
das hier nicht gemacht man kauft etwas
benutzt es etwa se Wochen lang und dann
wird man es los und kauft die neueste
Version von was auch immer das it Ding
gerade
[Musik]
ist die Menschen waren schon immer
irgendwie besessen davon etwas zu
besitzen
das Auto das sie fahren die Kleidung die
sie tragen so wie man auch sein Haus in
gutem Zustand verlassen will weil die
Leute einen danach beurteilen wie man
aussieht oder was man
[Musik]
trägt wenn man in dieser Branche mit
hochrangigen Führungskräften Sportlern
und Entertainern zusammenarbeitet
erwarten Sie einen bestimmten
Präsentationsstil
ich muss also in ihren Augen ein
bestimmtes Image aufrechterhalten damit
sie mich respektieren und meine Meinung
schätzen ich lasse mir also manchmal von
meiner Frau helfen wenn es um Stil geht
Markennamen und dergleichen sie scheint
sehr gut darin zu sein mich für den
Erfolg zu
kleiden und ich glaube fest daran dass
man sich wenn man sich jeden Tag gut
kleidet stärker und erfolgreicher
fühlt man kann sich im Grunde genommen
so anziehen dass man Erfolg hat ich ich
habe gesehen wie Menschen aus einer
Depression kamen quasi weil sie gut
aussahen fühl dich wie ein erfolgreicher
Typ und du bist ein erfolgreicher Typ
Fake make
[Musik]
it
das primäre Transportmittel hier in der
Siedlung ist der
Golfwagen jeder kann mit seinem
Golfwagen
angeben es gibt Golfwagen mit
geländerädern es gibt Golfwagen mit
besonderer Ausrüstung es gibt Sets die
man vorne aufstecken kann um das
golfauto wie einen Mercedes aussehen zu
lassen die Leute stecken 10 20 000 in
ein
golfauto die meisten Amerikaner sind
vernünftigtig und sagen nicht ich ziehe
in eine bewachte Siedlung um vor den
schwarzen zu fliehen die meisten Leute
denken nicht so sie sagen sich einfach
ich ziehe wegen der Sicherheit wegen der
höheren Immobilienwerte
hierhin das hat nichts mit Rasse zu tun
es gibt also eine Kluft so wird eine
Gemeinschaft isoliert diejenigen die da
scheinbar nicht reinpassen werden nicht
akzeptiert Menschen die nicht Golf
spielen Menschen die nicht in eine
bestimmte Kirche gehen diese Art von
Menschen fühlen sich oft
ausgeschlossen nein wir gehen nicht nein
hey halt dich fest
danke ich finde das toll dass du so gut
FST als wir hierher gekommen sind haben
wir gesehen dass am Ende der Straße ein
Park ist
die Kinder würden alle zusammen spielen
und alle hätten eine schöne Zeit
miteinander aber so ist das hier leider
nicht okay rauf auf den
Bordstein na dann mal los wir sehen
zumindest ethnisch aus wie die große
Mehrheit unserer Nachbarschaft und ich
habe mich immer noch nicht damit
abgefunden dass meine Kinder als die
anderen
nicht zu nah an die
Schaukeln ich will nicht dass du einen
Schlag an den Kopf
bekommst ich habe ganz normal aussehende
blondhaarige blauäugige nette Kinder und
dieses Mädchen ist auf dem Spielplatz
schreiend V max
weggerannt einfach weggerannt und sie
hat ihn immer wieder angeschrien und wie
schrecklich er sei und ihre Mutter sagte
ja das ist okay Schatz ich weiß
irgendwas stimmt hier nicht wenn mein
völlig normales Kind auf dem Spielplatz
keine Freunde
[Musik]
findet ich habe meinen Mann mehr als
einmal weinend
angerufen ich kann mit meinem Kind nicht
in den Park
[Musik]
gehen boomt der Konsum ist wieder in
Mode die luxusautohändler können sich
kaum noch an eine solche Zeit
zurückerinnern glauben sie dass ein
einzelner zu viel Geld verdienen kann
was meinen Sie dass wir das Einkommen
begrenzen sollten nicht wirklich nein
warum
wozu was wir wissen ist dass die
Menschen an der Spitze der
einkommensleiter alle
einkommenszuwechseel der letzten 30
Jahre erhalten haben die Menschen in der
Mitte der Einkommensverteilung haben
ihre Ersparnisse aufgebraucht sie haben
viel mehr Schulden angehäuft man muss
jede nur erdenkliche Spanne ausschöpfen
um seinen Platz in der Schlange zu
halten sie können sich bis zu 31 Tage
lang bis zu 1000 Pfund Leinen das ist
perfekt um ihren kurzfristigen Cashflow
zu managen die heute veröffentlichichten
Zahlen der Regierung zeigen dass eine
Rekordzahl von Menschen insolvent ist
wenn Sie die Einkommenssteuer nicht
innerhalb von 7 Tagen zahlen wird ein
Inkasso Team Kontakt mit Ihnen aufnehmen
und sie zu Hause aufsuchen der Brief
wurde am er geschrieben heute ist der
und was sagen die wann wollen die kommen
innerhalb von 7 Tagen du solltest sie
anrufen was so viel musst du
zahlen die Rechnung liegt bei 3inh 4000
Pfund aber ich brauche es für Sachen sie
wissen schon wenn die Kinder neue Jacken
brauchen neue Schuhe ich habe kein Geld
mehr ich muss es ja irgendwo
herbekommen
alles ist einfach so viel teurer
geworden und Lina will einen Computer
und man hat immer das Gefühl dass man
das dann auch tun muss weil ihre Freunde
haben auch einen und wenn sie keinen
bekommt ist sie
Außenseiterin man muss Abstriche machen
manchmal ruft die Schule an sie haben
das Essensgeld nicht bezahlt das komm
[Musik]
viele Menschen haben sich von einem
ziemlich einfachen finanziellen Leben
vor 1980 zu einem Punkt entwickelt an
dem sie völlig in Rechnungen versinken
sie sind alle
verschuldet für uns sind Schulden etwas
ich brauche einen Kredit um zur Schule
zu gehen oder um ein Haus zu kaufen aber
für die Wall Street ist es nur ein
Produkt das Sie kaufen und verkaufen und
verpen K es ist also nur eine weitere
Möglichkeit für Sie so viel Profit zu
machen wie sie wollen sie behandeln es
wie ein
[Musik]
Spiel
[Applaus]
ah ich habe jetzt einige Schulden bei
verschiedenen Firmen aber das einzige
was ich tun kann ist dass sie sich in
der Schlange anstellen und warten ich
muss für zwei Wochen zahlen die Hälfte
der Miete und die Säumnisgebühr und all
das es ist das reinste jonglieren ich
kann am Dienstag für den Cheeseburger
zahlen den wir heute
essen ja ja so ist es nun
Maly
[Musik]
es war einmal ein Kerl seine Kumpels
nannten ihn Joe und der fand heraus wir
haben zu viele
Schulden wir brauchen einen Kredit der
bis zum Zahltag reicht also ging er auf
dollarsdirect.ca dollardirect.ca ist
schnell und bequem du musst nur 18 Jahre
alt sein und einen festen Arbeitsplatz
haben und du bekommst direkt eine
sofortzahlungll
werben sie sich und erhalten Sie noch am
selben Tag
Bargeld eines der Dinge über die ich
heute sprechen will ist wie wir ein
sichereres Amerika schaffen können indem
wir es schaffen dass 5inhalb Millionen
Angehörige von Minderheiten ein Haus
kaufen wir wollen nicht dass irgendetwas
kleinedrucktes die Menschen daran
hindert ein eigenes Haus zu besitzen als
die Wall Street herausfand dass sie
diese hypothekenprodukte entwickeln
konnte hieß es wow das Geschäft des
Jahrhunderts wir müssen mehr davon
machen ein Haus ist immer das große Ding
das ist die Art und Weise wie die
Wirtschaft aufgebaut
ist man kauft ein Haus Immobilienwerte
steigen normalerweise es ist also ein
wichtiger Bestandteil deines
Ruhestands und wenn du dein Haus
verlierst kannst du in eine Lage geraten
in der du nicht mehr in den Ruhestand
gehen kannst sondern weiterarbeiten
musst
wenn man ein Haus kauft geht man mit
hundertausenden von Dollar eine Wette
ein dass dieses Haus einen Wert behält
und dass alles gut
[Musik]
geht Häuser die drastisch hinter dem
Trend zurückbleiben sind wirklich schwer
zu
verkaufen und wenn sie dann doch
verkauft werden dann für weniger Geld
ich glaube es wäre ein größerer Dru wenn
aktiv versuchen würden unser Haus zu
verkaufen wir versuchen einfach Schritt
zu halten und dafür zu sorgen dass wir
nicht so weit
zurückfallen ich bin die Eigentümerin
von Rench Maria homes und real estate es
ist mir ein Vergnügen schön dass sie es
geschafft haben der Preis für dieses
Haus beträgt
429900 und es steht auf einem Grundstück
von einem Viertel
Hektar und sie haben so viele Upgrades
gemacht es ist im Grunde ein brandneues
Haus ursprünglich wurde es 1981 gebaut
was mir daran gefällt achtung die Stufen
sie haben überall neues Laminat verlegt
die Fenster haben sie nicht erneuert die
sind noch einfach verglast nur in diesem
Raum sind sie doppelt
verglast aber sie haben eine komplett
neue Heizung und Klimaanlage eingebaut
die 12000 gekostet hat jetzt muss ich
Ihnen zeigen wie fantastisch diese
Schränke sind es sind ausziehschränke
und sie schließen sich ganz von
selbst hier ist ein Gasanschluss der
hier hat Propangas das ist eine
Kupferleitung
interessant und alle Häuser haben einen
anderen Charakter und einen anderen Stil
besonders dieses hier das ist ein
schönes Haus ein schöner Eingang ja es
hat einfach einen schönen
Stil das ist wirklich eine der besten
Straßen in dieser Gegend sie ist absolut
ruhig man sieht eigentlich niemanden
vorbeigehen außer die Leute die hier
wohnen und die teuersten Häuser in der
Nachbarschaft liegen hier die Straße
runter und am
See kommen Sie rein mal sehen was sie
davon
halten das erste Haus hat mit Abstand
die höchste Quadratmeterzahl ja ich habe
nicht das Gefühl dass sie viel dafür
bekommen ja mit großem Abstand aber ich
glaube zumindest wenn man das mit
unserem Haus vergleicht ist noch alles
gut wenn wir in eine Situation kommen
soll oll wo wir unser Haus verkaufen
müssen dann ginge es immer noch
einigermaßen gut
ja meistens ist mein erster Patient um
11 Uhr da das heißt ich stehe so gegen 8
auf sehe meine Sportsachen an und laufe
eine
Runde ich laufe etwa 45 Minuten bis eine
Stunde
ich liebe es draußen zu
laufen ich muss mich ziemlich anstrengen
aber es gibt keine andere Möglichkeit
als mich anzustrengen wissen sie man
steht mit dem Rücken zur Wand wenn man
eine Hypothek abbezahlen
muss er wurde gerade am Rücken operiert
und er hat buchstäblich am nächsten Tag
gearbeitet wurde am Mittwoch operiert
hat am Donnerstag und Freitag gearbeitet
und ist am Montag ins Büro gegangen er
hatte einen Krankheitstag konnte nicht
ins Büro gehen und Geld verdienen es ist
also wichtig dass er gesund bleibt für
sich selbst für unsere Familie und für
seine
Kunden die Regierung hatte Daten
gesammelt die zeigten dass es diese
riesigen Klassenunterschiede in der
Lebenserwartung gab und die Leute
glaubten den Daten nicht wirklich selbst
Leute die in wichtigen Positionen im
Gesundheitswesen arbeiteten wussten
nicht ob die Sterberaten oben oder unten
am hö
von Kokain zu Ketamin zu
kapitalistischen Prinzipien ich habe
versucht mein Lächeln wieder auf sein
Gesicht zu zaubern aber es ist mir nicht
gelungen also verabschiede ich mich
tränenreich von allen meinen Prinzipien
bis auf eins fange an mich mit dem Flow
zu unterhalten der mich auf diesen
rutschigen Weg geführt hat ich war nicht
immer so ich schätze es begann an dem
Tag an dem sie den SAR öffneten und sie
wegflog und mich hier am Boden liegen
zurückließ während ich mich an den
größten Schmerz schmiegte mein größtes
Ziel im Leben ist es einen Tag zu
überstehen meine Mama war 36 als sie
starb wenn ich so weiter trinke bin ich
das
auch stell dir mal vor mit 36 zu sterben
verdammt noch
mal all die Dinge die ich tun muss um zu
versuchen mein Leben zu verlängern das
bereits verkürzt ist weil ich arm
geboren wurde wenn ich es bis 70 schaffe
kann ich mich glücklich schätzen aber
auch nur wenn ich jeden Tag Salat
esse
jetzt weiß man natürlich aufgrund einer
wachsenden Zahl von Untersuchungen dass
Arbeitslosigkeit und Armut
gesundheitliche Folgen haben statt der
früheren Vorstellung dass es der Stress
des Geschäftsmannes ist der zu den
schlimmsten gesundheitlichen Problemen
[Musik]
führt eine Menge gesundheitsproeme die
reichen von Bluthochdruck über AIDS bis
hin zu hepatitis alle möglichen
Krankheiten jeder Tag über der Erde ist
ein guter Tag das ist das was mir gesagt
wurde das ist das was ich
weiß der Vater meiner Tochter ist
letztes Jahr
gestorben das hat mich ziemlich
umgehauen plötzlich war ich
alleinerziehende Mutter
er starb an
lieberkrebs ja es war wirklich
traurig aber es ist alles okay ich weiß
dass er jetzt an einem besseren Ort ist
er hat eine Weile gelitten verdammt viel
vermissen sie ihn ja das tue ich wir
haben 14 Jahre zusammengelebt eine lange
Zeit
ja
in Glas in Glasgow haben Männer die in
der ärmsten Gegend leben eine
Lebenserwartung von 54
Jahren in Indien leben dreiviertel der
Bevölkerung von 2 pro Tag oder weniger
niemand in Glasgow lebt von 2 pro Tag
oder weniger und dennoch haben Männer im
ernsten Teil glasgos eine
Lebenserwartung die Jahre unter dem
indischen Durchschnitt liegt und ich
dachte aha das ist es das wird es
erklären
benachteilig zu sein hat tiefgreifende
Folgen die sich in hohen Raten von
Selbstmord gewaltsamen Todesfällen
Alkohol und Herzkrankheiten
niederschlagen hier draußen hatte ich
meine erste
Sauferei es war Freitagabend wir kamen
hierunter und wir hatten eine Flasche
old Westminster dabei
es war witzig am Ende hatte ich meine
Zähne voller Sand und ich war benebelt
vom
Alkohol aber ich weiß noch wie ich
dachte das ist ekelhaft warum sollte
jemand sowas tun
wollen ich wünschte ich könnte süchtig
danach werden ins Fitnessstudio zu
gehen schtig nach Obst wer
sichtig nach Obst werden weißt du machen
was mein Sponsor
sagt aber ich brauche keine Bananen ich
sollte lieber mit dem Alkohol
aufhören der Alkohol gab mir das was ich
für Selbstvertrauen hielt er lässt einen
glauben dass man etwas wert
ist er ist wie ein
Schmerzmittel
[Musik]
jeder versucht auf seine eigene Weise zu
entkommen sie versuchen zu flüchten
indem sie irgendwelche Sachen tun
Marihuana und SAS od men mleren Alters
trinken wahrscheinlich oder tun etwas um
zu entkommen
älteren Leuten ist es vielleicht egal
weil sie alt sind sie müssen sich nicht
mehr mit sowas
auseinandersetzen aber jeder versucht
vor irgendwas zu
fliehen was tun Sie um zu fliehen ach
ich nehme mein Bier meine Zigaretten ab
und zu ein kleines Bier und das war es
dann auch schon ich schaue mir einen
guten Film an und gehe ins Bett
haben sie ein Lieblingsessen nein also
eigentlich Eiscreme ich mag
Eiscreme manchmal setze ich mich mit
einem ganzen Becher davon hin und esse
bis ich nicht mehr kann bis ich voll
bin ich finde man sieht gut aus wenn man
ein bisschen Fleisch auf den Knochen hat
das heißt dass man zu Hause gut
[Musik]
ist
ich bin die ganze Zeit sehr nervös und
die Nervosität ist einfach sogar die
Kunden sagen schon ich lächle nicht mehr
gestern hat mir z.B ein Mann gesagt sie
sehen aus als müssten sie sich beruhigen
und ich sage ich kann nicht und er meint
sie werden einen Herzinfarkt bekommen
und ich sage ich
[Musik]
weiß früher habe ich gearbeitet und bin
dann joggen gegangen ins Fitnessstudio
und so weiter und wo bin ich dann
gelandet jetzt gehe ich lieber nach
Hause und setze mich hin und esse
etwas es ist wirklich so man sagt sich
man war das wieder hart weil wir so
knapp bei Kasse sind ich werde mich
jetzt einfach in die Ecke setzen und ein
paar Chips essen bis ich wieder
runterkomme aber das ist ja auch nicht
der richtige
[Musik]
Weg wenn man einen Wirtschaftskurs
belegt lernt man Märkte auf rationalen
Entscheidungen
braucherbüroen angenommen sie schalten
den Fernseher ein und sehen sich die
Werbung an ich meine versuchen sie
informierte Verbraucher zu schaffen die
rationale Entscheidungen treffen ganz im
Gegenteil sie versuchen uninformierte
Verbraucher zu schaffen die irrational
handeln und das ist eine riesige
Industrie eine der größten Industrien
[Applaus]
überhaupt
die Leute hier sind ziemlich groß ja
gesund das wollte ich sagen angenehm
[Musik]
mollig
Mama bist du müde ja bin ich als ich
meine Tochter bekommen habe hatte ich
eine
Herzinsuffizienz und ich bin eigentlich
buchstäblich
gestorben es hat z Wochen gedauert bis
ich aus dem Koma erwacht bin ich habe
einfach Glück dass mein Herz noch
schlägt noch so lange um zu tun was noch
zu tun ist aber dadurch wird es nur noch
schwächer wann wurde Bluthochdruck bei
ihnen festgestellt im Jahr
2004 seid
ruhig seid still und macht die Tür
zu
mach alle Türen
zu alles muss zu sein und alle müssen
sich hinsetzen und still
sein
Okay zurück zu
mir
es beruhigt mich einfach zu wissen dass
nachts jemand auf uns alle aufpasst wenn
ich mit meinen Kindern alleine zu Hause
[Musik]
bin Nachricht gespeichert nächste
Nachricht Nachricht gespeichert nächste
Nachricht hey Bob sag wir lieben Dich
Daddy ich hab dich lieb sag gute Nacht
gute Nacht träum schön wie lieb habt ihr
Papa sehr lieb ich liebe
dich ich würde ihn gerne öfter sehen ich
sage immer ich wünschte ich hätte einen
Ehemann der einen n to5 Job hat dann
könnten wir abends zusammen nach Hause
kommen und uns gemeinsam um die Kinder
kümmern aber ich weiß dass das nicht
geht und ich weiß dass er uns einen
Lebensstil ermögl den wir ohne seine
harte Arbeit nicht haben
könnten wir wissen dass finanzielle Not
einer der Hauptfaktoren ist der Menschen
zu eheberatern treibt in den Gebieten in
denen die Ungleichheit am stärksten
zugenommen hat wir haben einen enormen
Anstieg der Scheidungsraten die Menschen
in der Mitte versuchen über die Runden
zu kommen und erleben dabei eine enorme
zusätzliche Belastung in ihrem
Leben Zeit ins Bett zu gehen kleines
Kälbchen kleines Kälbchen was ist heute
passiert dass dich zum Lachen gebracht
hat okay gibt mi einen Kuss nach einer
Woche bin ich erschöpft ich arbeite den
ganzen Tag und dann komme ich nach Hause
und habe zwei Kinder die ich füttern und
baden und denen ich Vorlesen muss um all
die Stunden wieder gut zu machen die ich
tagsüber nicht zu Hause
war ich habe euch
lieb Gute
[Musik]
Nacht
es ist furchbar ich habe enorme
Schuldgefühle weil ich die Mädchen nicht
sehen und ins Bett bringen kann und es
ist frustrierend wenn die Mädchen mehr
an sie gewöhnt sind als an mich hallo
hey ich bin so fertig von heute alles
gut und wie geht's dir mir geht's
gut dieses Blatt hier heißt GA für alle
kriminellen in der Gegend Seite für
Seite steht da wer verhaftet worden ist
und was er getan
hat manchmal gucke ich hier rein um zu
sehen ob meine Söhne Unsinn gemacht
haben während ich bei der Arbeit
das kommt von den Leuten die gestresst
sind weil die Wirtschaft hier im Arsch
ist und deshalb haben wir so eine
Situation Leute die Straftaten begehen
Überfälle weil sie frustriert sind
keinen Job finden sie brechen irgendwo
ein und versuchen in die Häuser anderer
Leute zu
kommen reine Wut gegen andere einer mit
dem
anderen sie suchen sich einfach
irgendwas um den Frust rauszulassen sie
haben ja sonst nicht viel zu
tun Psychologen und Soziologen die mit
Gewalttätern Arbeiten sagen immer wieder
dass mangelnder Respekt der Auslöser für
Gewalttaten und Aggressionen ist alles
was den Menschen bleibt ist die
Bewahrung ihrer Selbstachtung und wenn
die in irgendeiner Weise bedroht ist
kommt es zu gewalttätigen und
aggressiven Reaktionen
laut Polizei starben zwei Teenager und
ein 15jähriges Mädchen bei einer
Schießerei auf einer Geburtstagsfeier in
einem privaten Club das ist nicht
ungewöhnlich in den letzten Jahren sind
in dieser kleinen Stadt viele Menschen
getötet worden Highschool Schüler die
sich gegenseitig umbringen man weiß nie
wann man ausgeraubt wird
und ich würde gerne zu Fuß zur Arbeit
gehen oder mit
weil es nur etwa Meilen die Straße
runter ist aber ich habe zu viel Angst
mit dem Fahrrad zu fahren oder um
Mitternacht nach Hause zu laufen ich
habe immer Angst davor durch den Park zu
laufen immer jetzt wo die Hälfte der
Lichter aus ist ist es ein sehr
gefährlicher
Ort wir hatten letztes Jahr 116 Morde
dreal so viele wie in dieser Kirche
sitzen versuchen eine Epidemie von
Gewaltverbrechen zu bekämpfen die zum
großen Teil auf Drogen zurückzuführen
ist straßenfähiger schrotpflinte 12
Kaliber 12 Schuss in diesem
Trommelmagazin kein Visier weil es nicht
dafür ausgelegt ist ein Visier zu
[Musik]
brauchen
ich habe die Nase voll von diesem
Commonwealth ich bin gestresst diese
Stadt ist einfach so kaputt guckt euch
das doch an guckt mich
[Musik]
an niem
mehr ich halte diese Tür geschlossen
wenn es hier dunkel wird bin ich
drin es ist mir egal was da draußen ist
mir geht's gut
so und dieser Krieg gegen das Verbrechen
wird auf allen Ebenen geführt diejenigen
die es sich leisten können gehen dem aus
dem weg ziehen sich in bewachte
Siedlungen zurück von wo aus Sie den
neuen republikanischen Kampf um das
Überleben der Amerikaner beobachten
können
[Musik]
Mr Hawk ja wir sind hier um die grovees
zu besuchen gr V h
oug so hier ist es hatten Sie bisher
einen schönen Abend ja bisher war der
Tag ganz schön so alles klar danke schön
gern
geschehen
ein Nachbar hat ihn gesehen und uns
angerufen anscheinend wurde eines seiner
Hühner zerfleischt und ein anderes wurde
herausgerissen und
herumgejagt ich konnte die Sache mit dem
schlichten und ih beruhigen ihr wurde
ein Coyote gesichtet haben sie dir
irgendwelche Infos darüber gegeben nicht
viel nur dass er auf der Nordseite über
die Straße gelaufen ist hört sich an als
wäre es ein großes Tier gewesen ja hört
sich so
an
HT jetzt schon paar Monate hier rum oder
ich glaube
schon und das Pumpenhaus jemand hat da
oben ein paar Steine durch die Fenster
geworfen oh okay und das dieser andere
streunender Hund von dem wir gesprochen
hatten das müssen wir erledigen sieht ja
so aus als ob alles ordentlich auf den
Karten
vermerkt ich hole mir jetzt deine Tasse
Kaffee ein bisschen die Füße vertreten
und dann machen wir weiter klingt nach
einem Plan ich habe gerade einen
frischen für dich
gemacht Gewaltverbrechen und die Angst
die sie hervorrufen lähmen unsere
Gesellschaft schränken die persönliche
Freiheit ein und lösen unsere Verbindung
auf denen die wiederholt
Gewaltverbrechen begehen sollte gesagt
werden wenn du ein drittes
Gewaltverbrechen begehst wirst du
weggesperrt und zwar für immer Wal
ich bin mit einem Gramm Rauschgift
erwischt worden 1,5 g okay ich würde nie
jemandem weh tun außer mir selbst ich
hätte es nicht verkauft ich habe es auch
nicht an Kinder weitergegeben oder sowas
und dann stand ich vor gerecht aber sie
haben nicht mal versucht mir zuzuhören
sie haben das three strikes Gesetz gegen
mich angewandt und mich zu 25 Jahren
Haft verurteilt ich war in den letzten
17 Jahren in einer Kiste die nur ein
bisschen größer war als diese und
eingesperrt zu sein und so behandelt zu
werden wie ich hier behandelt wurde da
gibt es keinen lebenden Mann der nicht
genauso fühlen würde wie ich jetzt sie
haben Hass in mir
geschaffen ja ich bin im
Zuchthaus aber weißt du
was ich bin noch nie mit etwas erwischt
worden
ich muss mich vor den Frauen und den
Beamten ausziehen mich bücken und ihnen
mein Arschloch
zeigen ja gedemütigt es ist mehr als
das ich hatte alle alle in meinem Mund
die haben sie mir in der Roberson
Einheit
rausgeschlagen ich wurde fast zu Tode
geprügelt sie haben mir acht rien
gebrochen sie haben mir die Arme
ausgekugelt die Beine sie haben mir den
Kiefer gebrochen sie haben mir die
Zahnreihe rausgeschlagen sie haben mir
das augenbein gebrochen die Nase aber
wissen Sie was als mir drei Tage später
das erste Mal der Kopf abgerissen wurde
tat es nicht mehr so
weh und dann wurde ich zu einem
Monster ich hasse Menschen und weißt du
wie traurig das ist das zu
sagen ich bin hier so schlecht behandelt
worden ja ich könnte tatsächlich ich
könnte einen Mann töten ja das könnte
ich
wirklich und das ist traurig das ist
traurig weil ich besser erzogen wurde
als
das und was werde ich jetzt tun Miss
Brown wenn ich rauskomme was soll ich
tun mir einen Job bei McDonald's
besorgen ich werde 54 Jahre alt sein ich
kam mit 26 Jahren
hierher ich war auf dem College und
wurde da weggeholt
und was soll ich jetzt
tun denn was du warst bevor du ins
Gefängnis kamst ist nicht das was du
sein wirst wenn du unentlassen
[Musik]
wirst das ist ein Land das mit der
Sprache der Freiheit begonnen hat und
doch haben wir mehr Häftlinge pro Kopf
als irgendein anderes Land auf der
Welt
es besteht kein Zweifel daran dass es
viel unwahrscheinlicher ist inhaftiert
zu werden wenn man reich ist selbst wenn
man etwas Schreckliches getan
[Musik]
hat auf geht's wir haben hier vier unsen
massives Silber und 2,2 Karat
Diamanten das ist das reichste Jahr in
der Geschichte der
Menschheit die Reichen werden immer
reicher der Beweis ist auf unserer Liste
und das sind Macher das sind keine
Plutokraten das sind Macher die etwas
bewirken und wenn es ihnen gut geht geht
es uns allen
gut es gibt eine Religion die besagt
dass jeder davon profitieren wird das
hat fast nichts mit der realen Welt zu
tun sie versagt in der echten Welt
komplett versagen ist das falsche Wort
es ist kein Versagen für den Bruchteil
von einem%zent der Bevölkerung der
Reichtum anhäuft mehr als Sie es sich
vorstellen
der Einfluss des Geldes auf die Politik
hat in den letzten Jahrzehnten
dramatisch zugenommen die Leute an der
Spitze haben mehr Geld sie spenden den
Politikern immer mehr Geld und fordern
im Gegenzug niedrigere Steuersätze für
sich selbst und weniger strenge
Vorschriften für ihre
Unternehmen von den bescheidenen
Anfängen in einer Kleinstadt in arkans
bish hin zum weltweit führenden
Einzelhandelsunternehmen hat Walmart
seit 1962 einen langen Weg zurückgelegt
niemand außer vielleicht Sam der seine
ursprüngliche Idee nie aus den Augen
verloren hat hätte das bemerkenswerte
Wachstum des Unternehmens vorhersagen
können Walmart ist ein interessanter
Fall denn Walmart hat eine große Anzahl
von erdmilliardären hervorgebracht sie
sind in den Gemeinden in denen sie leben
zweifellos hoch angesehen und zweifellos
tun sie auch respektable Dinge sie
finanzieren Museen und Spenden Geld für
Krankenhäuser und sowas und dennoch in
vielen Gemeinden bekommen die Leute die
bei Walmart arbeiten zwar einen Lohn
aber auch Lebensmittelmarken im Grunde
zahlt also die Öffentlichkeit für die
Arbeit von
Walmart im Geschäftsjahr 2012 hatte
Walmart einen bruttmsatz von rund 446
Milliarden und der Nettogewinn lag bei
16,7 also fast 17 Milliarden Dollar ich
habe kein Problem damit wenn ein
Unternehmen Gewinn macht wie ich schon
sagte ich hatte mein eigenes Unternehmen
aber wenn man auf Kosten der Menschen
die die Arbeit tun Gewinn macht und die
dann von Lebensmittelmarken leben dann
ist es eine moralische Frage wenn man
die Entscheidung trifft okay wir kürzen
die Arbeitsstunden damit wir mehr Gewinn
machen denn sie wissen was sie
tun wir haben herausgefunden dass
wohlhabender Menschen das Verfolgen
ihrer eigenen Interessen im Gegensatz zu
kollektiven Interessen eher als
moralisch und gut empfinden wir
beobachten sogar eine Moralisierung der
Gier diese geiz ist geil
malität K stellt wirklich die
psychopathischen Denker heraus Menschen
die keine Empathie haben denn wenn man
einmal erfolgreich ethische Erwägungen
ausgeklammert hat ist man unglaublich
effizient ich denke es ist nichts falsch
daran es bequem haben zu wollen ich weiß
nicht mal ob es falsch ist reich sein zu
wollen aber das Bestreben der Wall
Street ist es you money zu haben
und you money heißt das ist eine so
große Menge an Geld dass man zum Telefon
greifen und sagen kann W man will
ohne irgendwelche
Konsequenzen eine der notwendigen
Illusionen für die Allgemeinheit ist
dass wir in einer kapitalistischen
Wirtschaft
leben aber die reichen glauben das nicht
eine Minute lang sie bestehen auf einen
mächtigen stat der sie vor der
Marktdisziplin schützt wenn Goldman Sax
also ein riskantes Geschäft macht sind
sie im Grunde genommen geschützt wenn
die Firma zusammenbricht könen Sie mit
der Mütze in der Hand zu mutterst rennen
und sich aus der Patsche helfen
lassen guten Morgen das ist ein
entscheidender Moment für Amerikas
Wirtschaft Probleme die auf den
Kreditmärkten entstanden sind und sich
zuerst im Bereich der subprime
Hypotheken zeigten haben sich auf unser
gesamtes Finanzsystem
ausgeweitet es war eine düstere Woche an
der Wall Street an den letzten fünf
Handelstagen hat der Dow Jones allein
1400 Punkte verloren die Investoren sind
sich einig dass eine entscheidende Woche
ist um zu sehen ob die Regierung
eingreifen und die Wirtschaft heilen
kann oder nicht ich bin ein starker
Verfechter des freien Unternehmertums
unter normalen Umständen bin ich der
Meinung dass Unternehmen die schlechte
Entscheidungen treffen die Möglichkeit
haben sollten ihr Geschäft aufzugeben
aber das sind keine normalen
Umstände wissen sie der Präsident hat
immer wieder gesagt dass es das Geld des
Volkes ist damit hat er recht es ist das
Geld des Volkes aber jetzt sind es die
Schulden des
Volkes das ist ein Schmerz der mich für
den Rest meines Lebens begleiten wird
aber sie dürfen 480 Millionen behalten
ich habe eine ganz einfache Frage an Sie
ist das
fair das Spektakel dieser Banker die in
hohem Maße dazu beigetragen haben die
westlichen Volkswirtschaften in die Knie
zu zwingen und sich trotzdem weiter
bezahlen so viel Geld wie sich die
meisten nicht einmal vorstellen können
und Sie glauben wirklich dass sie es
wert sind manchmal treffe ich sie in der
Öffentlichkeit und sie sagen Max wann
begreifst du endlich dass der
Kapitalismus so funktioniert ich sage
dann das ist nicht wie der Kapitalismus
funktioniert so geht der Kapitalismus
hoffnungslos und katastrophal
[Musik]
schief ich kann am besten für die Wall
Stre Geminde sprechen weil ich ihr
gegenüzeen sie ich der Wall Stre heute
härter arbeiten als je
zuvor ohne zu wissen ob sie jemals
aufsteigen können und wann dieses Rennen
für sie
[Musik]
endet dr ist ein klinischer
Psychologe und wahrscheinlich ist er vor
allem dafür bekannt dass er Menschen
hilft mit Unsicherheit umzugehen und in
Zeiten der Ungewissheit optimale
Motivation und Leistung aufrecht
zuuerhalten
[Applaus]
ich habe es mir zur Aufgabe gemacht den
Menschen in dieser schwierigen Zeit zu
helfen denn in meiner Praxis als
Psychologe habe ich das Gefühl dass
meine Klienten bei mir nach Antworten
suchen meine Dissertation ist die erste
Studie die in den Vereinigten Staaten in
den letzten 50 Jahren durchgeführt wurde
sie trug den Titel die Unfälle der Wall
Street eine Begutachtung der Verletzten
und meine Ergebnisse zeigen im Grunde
dass wir uns derzeit in einer
anschlusskrise
[Musik]
befinden
wir sollten nicht denen aus der Patsche
helfen die die leichtsinnige
Entscheidung getroffen haben ein Haus zu
kaufen von dem sie wussten dass sie es
sich niemals leisten
können dieses Wort hörte man oft die
gierigen Hausbesitzer hier geht es um
arme Leute die mit ihrer zweiten
Hypothek einen Fernseher gekauft haben
und es sei ihre Schuld und sie seien
gierig gewesen das ist die Mentalität
gib dem Opfer die
[Musik]
Schuld
ich habe immer wieder meine Kreditkarten
benutzt um zu leben und dann war ich mit
den ersten Karten am Limit ich bin am
Ende und ich werde
umziehen ich muss sehr bald umziehen in
den nächsten paar Wochen das war's so
sieht
aus es gibt eine Menge Daten die darauf
hindeuten dass die soziale Milität auf
ef die Menschen erreichen trotz harter
Arbeit nicht den amerikanischen
Traum wer ist es dann der Wohlstand
erreicht oft sind es diejenigen die von
vorne rein in den Wohlstand
hineineeboren
[Musik]
wurden ich habe das Gefühl dass ich
damit gesegnet bin alles zu haben was
ich brauche ich könnte nicht glücklicher
sein ich könnte mir nicht mehr wünschen
[Musik]
mit 15 verließe ich bigstone GAP
Virginia und trampte quer durch den
ganzen Kontinent nach
Südkalifornien und ich hatte einen guten
Job ich war jung heterosexuell das Leben
war schön
ich dachte daran nach Hollywood zu gehen
und der nächste Tom Cruise oder sowas zu
werden aber dann ist das anders
[Musik]
gekommen meine Mutter hatte eine Herz
und Lungeninfektion und sie starb im
Jahr
89 es hat mich
erdrückt
ich bin in eine Art Spirale geraten die
falschen Dinge getan um über die Runden
zu
kommen und das führte mich auf einen
langen Weg den ich nicht gehen wollte
aber ich tat es ich hing mit den
falschen Leuten rum Tat die falschen
Dinge versuchte Geld zu verdienen und
versuchte einfach zu
überleben ich ging für ein Jahr ins
Gefängnis kam wieder raus und konnte
immer noch nicht K denken und dann habe
ich Kinder bekommen zu dieser Zeit
konnte ich sie nicht bei mir haben weil
ich so kaputt
war aber nach meiner Herzinsuffizienz
bin ich
aufgewacht es war ein wegruf den ich
brauchte ein dringend notwendiger wegruf
und ich habe es
geschafft seitdem geht es mit mir Berg
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
auf
wir glauben einfach nicht dass die
Regelschule ein guter Ort für Kinder ist
die auch nur ein bisschen über der Kurve
sind also wahrscheinlich
Homeschooling wenn sie nicht auf dem
richtigen Weg bleiben die Meilensteine
nicht erreichen die Ziele die sie
erreichen sollen dann wird sich das
langfristig darauf auswirken welches
Ergebnis sie
erzähen keine Herausforderung ist
dringlicher keine Debatte ist
wichtiger wir können uns entweder mit
einem Land abfinden inem es einer
schrumpfenden Zahl von Menschen wirklich
gut geht während eine wachsende Zahl von
Amerikanern kaum über die Runden kommt
oder wir können eine Wirtschaft
wiederherstellen in der jeder eine FA
Chance bekommt jeder seinen fairen
Beitrag leistet und jeder nach den
gleichen Regeln
[Applaus]
spielt die Ungleichheit ist nicht auf
schlechte Äpfel zurückzuführen sondern
das Fass ist
schlecht es sind die Institutionen die
das Vorankommen über alles andere
stellen dass es in Ordnung ist das
Gesetz zu brechen wenn das heißt dass
man dadurch mehr Profit für das
Unternehmen macht ohne darauf zu achten
was die Konsequenzen für das System als
Ganzes
sind was ich ablehne ist das Gefühl dass
es da draußen einen Mechanismus gibt
gegen den man überhaupt nichts tun kann
das ist einfach nicht wahr wenn Sie das
ändern wollen können Sie es
[Musik]
ändern
mein Name ist le tayor und ich bin heute
hier um meine Stimme zu erheben für
meine Kollegen und alle die in der
Fastfood Industrie zu kämpfen
haben was würden sie dem Chef von he für
den sie arbeiten gerne
sagen ich gebe nicht einem bestimmten
Unternehmen die Schuld die Wahrheit ist
dass die Menschen im Stich gelassen
werden solange die Regierung die
Bedeutung der huslichen Pflege in diesem
Land kennt diese Probleme sind tief im
System verwurzelt und es ist das System
das sich ändern
muss mein Name ist Janet Sparks und ich
bin Walmart Mitarbeiterin im Laden
Nummer
1102 wenn ich daran denke dass unser
Geschäftsführer letztes Jahr über 20
Millionen Dollar verdient
hat mehr als das Tausendfache eines
durchschnittlichen Walmart
Mitarbeiters bei allem Respekt
dann muss ich sagen dass ich das nicht
für richtig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
halte ich wünschte wir wären nie in
diese Lage geraten ich wünschte wir
hätten nie diese außergewöhnlich hohen
Vergütungen gehabt mir war nicht klar
dass es s weit kommen würde vielleicht
wussten andere immer ganz genau dass
dies das Ergebnis davon sein würde aber
ich denke das ist bedauerlich und ich
bedauere
es ich glaube man hat irgendwie immer so
ein Gefühl im Hinterkopf dass man nicht
Teil von etwas Gutem ist aber ich hatte
kein klares Gefühl dass ich etwas aktiv
schädliches tue als dann die Finanzkrise
ausbrach begann ich mich wirklich unwohl
zu fühlen und ich fragte meinen Chef ob
die Öffentlichkeit uns das jemals
verzeihen würde also die Rettungsaktion
und er sagte mir nun es ist so die
Öffentlichkeit vergisst immer die
Öffentlichkeit vergisst nach der und
darlehenskrise hat die Öffentlichkeit
vergessen dass die langfristige
kapitalverwaltung in die Luft geflogen
ist die Öffentlichkeit vergisst immer
und die Öffentlichkeit wird es wieder
vergessen und wir werden weitermachen
und es wird wieder alles normal machen
Sie sich also keine Gedanken darüber in
Großbritannien haben die 1000 reichsten
Menschen mehr Vermögen als die Ärmsten
40%. in den USA besitzen die obersten
0,1% ungefähr das gleiche Vermögen wie
die unteren
90%.
[Musik]
ich bin seit fast 11 Monaten trocken das
ist die längste Zeit die ich je vom
Alkohol weg
war und ich habe gelernt dass mein
Spielraum für Fehler sehr klein ist ich
meine wenn ich zu einem Drink greife
fange ich wieder von vorne
an
[Musik]
es gibt einen Plan ein zweites Tor zu
bauen und diese 10 bis 20 Häuser
komplett von den restlichen Häusern zu
trennen die jetzt schon komplett
getrennt sind ich glaube es ist meh eine
statusse als eine angstse es gibtereit
ein von ihnen mit einer
[Musik]
Waffe um ehrlich zu sein würde ich
lieber in Florida Leben einer meiner
nächsten Motivationsschübe wird es sein
dass ich irgendwann nach Florida ziehe
und dort einen Zweitwohnsitz haben
[Musik]
möchte
ich bereue nichts nächste Woche lebe ich
vielleicht unter einer
Brücke aber ich habe es wenigstens
versucht wenn ich Millionärin oder sowas
sein könnte und ein großes Haus kaufen
könnte mit ungefähr 50
Zimmern dann hätte ich meine ganze
Familie be mir das würde ich lieben ich
würde es
[Musik]
lieben es ist immer so viel zu tun ich
wünschte ich könnte die Kinder ein
bisschen mehr sehen oder ich würde gerne
sagen wir gehen heute Abend mal essen
ich erwarte nicht viel vom Leben ich
wünschte nur es wäre ein bisschen
einfacher
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich werde ich wieder hier
landen aber nicht weil ich in eine
Schule gegangen bin und einen ganzen
Haufen Kinder erschossen habe oder
jemanden vergewaltigt habe oder sowas
sondern weil ich wahrscheinlich beim
Stehlen eines Brotes erwischt werde und
dafür eine lebenslange Haftstrafe
[Musik]
bekomme
down โอ้ เย
[Musik]
กป